uh and so you know someone like saying
basically i i know sam i say this guy
and i see his videos i'm like oh these
these are great videos he's only getting
you know a couple thousand views let's
say right now but
basically what what this world would let
me do is as an early believer i can bet
on sam i could say i like this guy's
content i think this guy's gonna blow up
and i can kind of vote for his success i
can give him some so i can buy his coin
which gives him money to like make
better content it gives him a little
boost of morale to keep going um but it
also lets me go on the ride with him
because i think we've all been there
before we discover a band early or a
brand early or an influencer early and
then you're you're you believe in them
and you're so you're so right they
actually do take off they never knew you
they never had a real relationship with
you and you didn't benefit from the fact
that you know kim carter if you knew kim
kardashian back when she was just paris
hilton's closet organizer uh and you
thought she was great you missed out on
the ride and and so this lets your true
fans go on the ride with you and it
turns your fans into sort of
shareholders with you and so
oh bro i study this stuff you know kim
kardashian where did this come from i
have to know i must know and uh and sure
enough there's a story and so you know
sam let's say i would bet on sam sam
would get that cash so sam could use
that to make a cooler video and when sam
makes that video and he gets more
followers
they have to buy in at a higher price
point than i did because now sam's more
established so my stock is going up i'm
earning instead of just following right
i own instead of just following which is
the way the world works today with
twitter and instagram you just follow
you don't earn and then the you know
furthermore sam could say hey you know
what how do i make my coin really
valuable to hold what if i kind of only
fans it and i said i'm going to do some
exclusive stuff with only my coin
holders who hold over 100 of my coin so
it's up to him to decide if he wants to
make his coin more juicy more more
enticing to hold which again will make
my stock go up if i know sam's the kind
of guy he connects with his fans he's
going to put in the effort that's going
to make these coins more valuable and so
it takes this idea that's been around
for a long time the thousand true fans
the thing that any artist knows that
they need those real believers and it
turns them into people who actually
benefit from your rise and so that's
what i think that's the good thing that
i think will come of this aside from you
know destroying facebook and all that
good stuff i think the good thing that
will come of this it'll make being a
taste maker and a curator
like a job pretty much you can actually
get paid for having good taste for
following for believing in somebody
early on which is the way that things
should be i think yeah sean how are you
better at explaining this than me also i
i i'm kind of uh
i'm not offended but uh that's awesome
well dude when i first shouted out big
cloud yeah i got a lot of
okay i got to come up with a reason that
i like this besides i think this is
going to make a lot of money for me uh
so i started thinking about what what is
the appeal here and i hate to defend
myself and in doing something
why does this
yeah
that's true i did i i remember it uh but
yeah sean just to add which is really
interesting uh like you said there's
actually never been a way to actually
invest in someone when they're small and
make money on their rise like in like
this easily this efficiently uh and
what's really interesting is there's
actually yet another interesting kind of
like layer on it which is once you
invest in someone
your bias is to be supportive your bias
is actually to be hey i want this guy to
succeed i want this person to to be
something and you can align in a way
that you can't really on like you know
without that mechanism like being able
to buy into someone you know uh uh
creates kind of an incentive that
doesn't exist and what's crazy is that
um even bitcoin you know bitcloud
diamond all these apps uh they're
actually very positive discourse a lot
of it um even though you know there's
not really any kind of you know there's
not like there's less moderation than
traditional social media right um and
the reason i think is basically you're
investing in people right you're going
long uh and and when you give people the
ability to to like move money around
right people naturally go long and when
they go long they actually uh uh get
aligned and want to support you um and
so weirdly enough like i love like when
people say like money is like the root
of all evil you know like money is bad
and and i think that's part of why
people reacted weirdly to bitcloud
because like oh money prices whatever
but like if you just look past that for
two seconds you'll see that it's
actually being used as an alignment tool
that's making
a lot of positive things happen that
haven't happened
[Music]
you